president Trump hasn't mentioned the
death toll since it reached 100,000 he
has threatened to rein in social media
companies claiming they're interfering
with free speech the president is
expected to sign an executive order
today targeting Twitter and other
well-known platforms Paula Reid is at
the White House Paula what does the
president hope to accomplish with this
good morning Anthony I just got off the
phone with a senior administration
official who confirms that the White
House is expected to issue an executive
order that would curtail some of the
legal protections for social media
companies I'm told this is still being
revised it's still being drafted it
could change but this would likely set
off a significant legal battle looking
at the extent to which the government
can regulate a private publishing
platform and last night Facebook founder
Mark Zuckerberg we did on this order I
have to understand what they actually
would intend to do Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg
responded late Wednesday to the
president's efforts to possibly regulate
social media in general I think a
government choosing to just censor a
platform because they're worried about
censorship doesn't exactly strike me as
the the reflex there on Wednesday the
president accused social media of trying
to silence conservative voices after
Twitter flagged his tweets about mail-in
ballots for potentially misleading
information after he claimed without
evidence that ballots would be stolen
and forged the president's ongoing feud
with his preferred social media platform
comes as the United States reaches a
grim milestone of 100,000 Cova deaths
the president did not address the death
toll Wednesday but his Democratic rival
former Vice President Joe Biden released
a video offering condolences to families
and attacking the Trump administration's
response if the administration acted
just one week earlier to implement
social distancing and do what it had to
do just one week sooner as many as 36
thousand of these deaths
the Trump campaign offered a different
take on the president's handling of the
pandemic
down foreign travel get ventilators and
tests now raise unemployment benefits
relieves two families but the economy is
likely going to be the biggest factor in
this election so far the White House is
still mulling additional options to help
address historic unemployment CBS News
has learned the White House wants to
focus on measures that would stimulate
the economy as opposed to just cutting
additional checks
officials say the White House is open to
extending some unemployment insurance
but not the six hundred dollar bonus
payment that Congress approved through
July as well as possible payroll tax
cuts and reducing capital gains taxes
they're also considering tax deductions
to encourage people to eat out and
travel face coverings have also become a
politically charged issue on the
campaign trail and yesterday dr. Falchi
says he wears a face covering because he
believes it's not only effective but
shows respect for other people
Tony all right Paula thank you very much